this video is not quick mate I really am
a millionaire
I really have home I really did buy a
property with normally from scratch in
lockdown
by the definition of buy because some
people say it's actually lease option
therefore you didn't buy it you obtained
it controlled it got cash flowing from
him but you don't have the title deeds
definition or buy it says to acquire the
possession off all right to buy by
paying or promising to pay an equivalent
especially in money so I think you can't
really awesome with the dictionary also
I did it with no money because any money
that I use there's small amount money
that I needed on legal fees I made from
scratch in deal sourcing which you'll
see exactly how I did step by step in
this video enjoy from this evening I
must give the British people a very
simple instruction you must stay at home
the people of this country will rise to
that challenge and we will come through
it stronger
the
ever geez she's gonna be tough yeah hey
my name is Samuel lead I'm a property
investor an entrepreneur guess where I
am
I am a home because on the 23rd of March
2020 everybody was told they had to work
from home stay at home in lockdown
so I decided as a property investor an
entrepreneur rather than just staying at
home and keeping a low profile and doing
nothing I'm going to do what I usually
do before wrong now if you've seen my
YouTube videos before you'll see me
making money viewing houses out on the
road meeting people negotiating I can't
do that from home however I have found a
way whereby you can make money from home
with a laptop with a phone and I'm going
to show you exactly how I made 3600
pounds from scratch with a laptop on the
phone
and bought a house using practically no
money from home from scratch yeah
9th of April so 9th of April Surveyors
ago ground properties just today Mac
says he's a surveyor around one of his
investors properties so max that's great
thanks for the confirmation but in
that's gonna serve helpful definitely
need some more details of surveyors that
bed to go out to houses from you alright
see you later bye there we go
if you gues imagine go into the house
and you get a solicitor to work its
Lister's are working because they work
beforehand there's no excuses man
there's a lot of good opportunities in
Wales for stuff like beet rr3 a bit
house this was just literally on an hour
ago I mean these properties are coming
up look at this an hour an hour there's
flats there's houses
this one's on four fifty nine nine fifty
a little house South Wales that's fun
see what we can see what we can do when
there's only one picture of the house it
tends to be it's in pretty bad condition
hello hi there I'm just ringing my name
is Samuel I'm ringing about the property
I've seen it on gumtree it's some four
sixty thousand pound on
is it still available well I mean I mean
I don't know how that works exactly
because I'm we're in lockdown he used
are you still doing viewings yeah okay
well that would be great if you could
arrange my name is Samuel Leeds then the
direct I'm not the first time by now I'm
I was I'll be looking to buy this
property just to refurb it and then
refinance it as an investment excellent
thank you so much
Cheers bye
so he said he's going to put me in touch
with the owner died wrapped which is
really cool so this Wales positivism 469
thousand and fifty nine nine fifty I've
been pointed to this cellar direct the
seller has sent me it's not really a
video tour it's all the pictures and to
be fair it does look pretty rough but
it's also come with a survey with
builders quotes basically this property
I think that the owner was gonna give it
up himself but he's not moving
so now he just wants to sell it to be
fair a lot of people are liquidating at
the moment so in order for that to stack
up going through everything nice I'm
confident in himself for a hundred
thousand pounds the build was quote
twenty one thousand to do it up so I'm
thinking if I bought a 60 grand even if
the asking price it could work but I'm
gonna comment before an offer and see if
I can get it for mid forties high
forties and all still happens because at
that price it's a steal and know that if
we were to do it up about
and I say I I'm not gonna be buying this
house myself I'm passing this on for a
fee and then the money that I get I'm
gonna use that to put two wars and lease
option agreement or at least that's the
plan so a bit of really good news my off
has been accepted on the South Wales
property of 49,000 pounds now that
property done up will easily be worth
one hundred thousand pounds I've got a
builder's quote done I've got the survey
already done I literally don't need to
view it so as long as I'm 100 percent
honest when I sell this deal with the
with the investor I'm gonna email out
and I'm just gonna I'm just gonna be
really honest I'm going to say look
firstly you need to sign an NDA when
they sign an NDA I'm then gonna say here
are all the details I'm gonna give them
the address I'm gonna give them the
builders quotes I'll give them the
survey I'll give everything I've got and
I'll say that's that they can't cut me
out of the deal because they've signed
an NDA
they can't go direct to the vendor
because they've signed an NDA if they
want it they need to pay me three
thousand pounds plus bat okay let's get
the CMOS and he'll piers have structured
the email so brr probably deal in south
wales no stamp duty that's going out to
324 property investors that have all
come from my facebook ad which cost me
about 30 pence per lead do investors
have excellent property investment
opportunity that fits perfectly with
this time of the lockdown
boom fact check figures bonuses vision
how to secure and take a deep breath
let's send message sent and this is what
it looks like cool
let's wait and see what happens
this deal I should have in Wales he's
getting quite a lot of response now so I
made it very clear how to respond I just
said how to secure step 1 respond to
this email saying I have the funds and
I'm interested
step 2 sign an NDA and provide ID and
proof of funds 3 receive the full
details and karaokes diligence for pay
me the money you pay the finder's fee of
3000 pound plus fat thighs receive
support and access to power team ready
to complete and I've got people I mean
some people are just saying whatever is
it more details but I'm interested we've
just got a message now come through I
have the funds have him interested this
is all happening this is all happening
fast
I mean people sign there and I've just
responded and said hey you're happy to
send me your proof of funds
I said no she's sending me a proof of
funds and saying she's interested guess
what that means she's about to go down
it's gonna happen it's just a matter of
time now
okay so I've just typed up a really
brief confidentiality agreement now the
purpose of this is just to stop the
investor trying to cut me out of the
loop and I'm doing this from scratch so
I haven't got access to all my documents
they visit they're all at the office so
I thought I just did completing scratch
so I am going to email this over as a
PDF to each investor who's interested
sorry if you can hear my children
screaming in the background but I guess
this is life
so this is my ad where I found my buyer
my investor and as you can see I've just
turn the campaign off now but for 38
pence per lead with 356 actual facebook
leads 27,000 impressions so that's how
many people have seen the ad and a total
spend of 134 pounds and sixpence I mean
I'm pretty happy with that ad I might
turn it back on at some point but right
now I don't need loads more investors
and I can literally download the file
and here my investors that have just
come from the last week 38 pencil a
night absolutely fantastic and these
guys all want to give me money and
Belinda will be on this list somewhere
let me see if I can find her and Belinda
is right here with her email and that is
how she got the deal fantastic
so a signed agreement and with a little
bit of luck oh yeah
mm my count good morning is it Belinda
um Wow how you doing I think I sent you
over the property details of the buyer
service refinance and South Wales
yesterday how did you get on going over
the figures due diligence did you need
anything for me
yeah absolutely yeah yeah let me send
you okay I'm just sending as we speak a
breakdown of everything that's actually
going to happen in the property I
probably should have sent you this
yesterday really let me send you a
breakdown with all the itemized points
including the skips the electrics
consuming you net absolutely everything
even though even like Thailand
yeah in Thai reefer yeah because as you
can see on the pictures it needs it does
need a lot of work but that's good
that's a good thing because it that's
the whole purpose of these types of
deals there's always a small amount of
race I wouldn't have emailed the
property out unless I was quite
confident in it I've not seen it myself
because of not down but but I've gotten
on it having builders go up so the
property is probably more valuable than
even me seeing it myself because the
builders this is something that yeah
yeah thank you very welcome you very
welcome okay bye
so I am pretty confident that one of the
investors are gonna buy that deal but
I'm not just gonna wait and see what
happens while I'm waiting I'm gonna go
and find more deals online I'm gonna
jump on gumtree right move and this time
I'm looking for lease option agreement
that's where you buy a house now but you
pay for it later you have the option to
buy it at a later date so it means you
don't have to put down any money you can
stop benefit from cash flow maybe from
some capsule appreciation right away I'm
pumped
let's do this right move is kind of a
no-go right now because estate agents do
seem to be close so I'm gonna go back to
geometry I'm kind of tempted to do
properties for rent and then I can say
to the guys who are speak to I can say
look I'll rent it off you but then I'll
buy off you down the line then itami
thinking I want a full went so the
property for sale there's just so many
properties for sale in so many different
places probably for sale in
stoke-on-trent
this one just can't eight minutes ago 39
minutes ago like people that say that
we're not enough leads there's just that
just is 70,000 pound to bed house in
stoke-on-trent let's see if we've got a
telephone number okay this one hasn't
got a phone number so that's not really
very good I only have one nine minutes
ago now this one looks very interesting
because it says ideally looking to sell
but would consider renting now that for
me
offers only over 70,000 pounds I tell
you what I will drop my friend Joe an
email I would preferably rent it first
and then have an option to buy it for
70,000 pounds I can just send you a I
can drop a text message over to you and
kind of one thinking hello okay so
basically and I mean kind of half
conversations with this guy called Joe
and Joe saying he's open he's in
negative equity so I'm gonna send him a
text message and see what he thinks
so I sent Joe over an email of a formal
offer on lease option agreement subject
to the survey he responded with from
questions seemed kind of happy said he
was going to speak to his solicitor so I
sent him over a memorandum of
understanding heads of terms and in the
meantime continue to talk to more
motivated sellers to this guy Ian who
messaged me he saw my facebook advert he
stole all his details he told me he's
mortgage outstanding him out cuz I added
that has a question on the facebook on
the responder his property is on
Rightmove it's on the market for one
hundred and fifteen thousand he bought
it in 2007 for one hundred and five
thousand he's more easy mortgaged up to
the hills but the property hasn't really
gone up in value at all the crazy thing
is in 2005 it was bought for one hundred
and twenty seven thousand so 2005 really
good dropped a little bit he bought it
now it's just stayed the same he's a
negative equity and I honestly think if
I gave him what he wants hundred fifteen
he wouldn't make any money pretty much
he made a few thousand pounds but if I
say to him listen how about I'll just
take on the mortgage I'll give you 150
which is the price that you want but
I'll pay on my terms and my terms is in
five years like this is just gonna
happen
it's a great product release options is
a great product is a great service I
just think this is gonna happen Matt I'm
excited so thank you Facebook ad it was
shot to throw in him so quick because
this message just came through a few
minutes ago it's just gonna end up with
two or three lease options by the end of
it by the end of the day sending the
text hello my name's Samuel
I've just received an email a few
minutes ago with the details of your
property it came through I think you
keep through on the Facebook ad sounds
interesting if you'd like to have a
quick conversation give me a call back
on this number I'll drop you a text
message as well and hopefully speak to
you later on today thanks again
fantastic that's great news what I'll do
I will send you over an invoice all
right they're interested like this guy
this guy this guy like now I'm going to
email them back and I'm gonna say to
them I'm really sorry the deals been
sold however there will be more deals
coming real soon what that would do is
that will almost train them that's
quicker next time she saying sending
your first deal from scratch to a new
list of investors is always hard is
always hardest because they don't know
the crack but is now I'm gonna be
training those investors bye bye same
insult next time I sent it out it will
sell twice as fast the third time twice
as fast again and this is this is just
just just easier and easier and making
money gets easier and easier and the
fact that I'm doing this in lockdown
without viewing the houses having
descendants of Ayres it's kind of cool
right now it's 11:59 it's a beautiful
day although my eyes are itching because
of the hay fever and it is the 9th of
April Thursday and you can see that
right there hopefully now I've just
received
3000 pounds plus VAT into my bank which
is 3,600 pounds investors are buying
right now I'm gonna call my investor and
just confirm that she has paid the money
so she's paid the money I'm working on a
lease option agreement deal and I'm only
like a week into this from lockdown from
my house hello Belinda its Samuel you
okay I'm really well I just thought I'd
give you a quick call just to check the
money's come in okay so we've received
the we've received the three thousand
six hundred pounds so thank you very
much for that hopefully this this virus
kind of clears up and we're able to
leave our houses again soon but listen
it's really good to do business with you
and it's released we can still buy
houses even if we're even if we're
locked in our houses we can still buy
properties which is which is good
because the surveyors some surveyors are
still going out I hope it all works out
really well and I look forward to seeing
the progression thank you so much bye
bye now so there we go it's just super
happy lady investing in property April
9th
middle of lockdown this is real man and
3,600 pounds in my back okay
absolutely credible news that only if I
made three thousand six hundred pounds
and deal stunning but this is the heads
of terms to the lease option agreement
signed with Joe so Joe I freaking love
you I'm sure you'll probably watch this
but you enjoyed the deal as well and
what's date
my wife is reven we're gonna keep the
video me how I been the last week doing
this challenge was it worth it for a
free house free art I'm 3,600 from home
listen I've been doing all this but I'll
be running the business as well I just
dunno I've been working like crazy but
listen as well this whole the whole
reason I've done this video to show that
you can make money even while in
lockdown so that you can continue in
form so it's ultimately to show that
I've got a house but to help other
people more than anything is the fact
that people have been joining in doing
the privacy lockdown challenge I'm going
to show a little clip that I had said to
me had a video sent to me yesterday for
a 17 year old kid who's got two three
houses on a lease option agreement
sounds too good to be true
sounds incredible people are doing it so
recently open a Facebook out saying that
if your dad or your homeowner and you've
got an issue with your property coming
speak to me came across a lady who left
me her details for one property now the
issue of that property was she sold it
she well she was going through the
process of selling an end the guy who
was buying it from her backed out
because of the whole current of our
situation so she's been sort of left in
a bit of a predicament really and I've
said you know I needed to have been
research on your property but would you
consider a written to my scheme she said
yeah what would that consist of so I
talked I talked her through it you know
more or less how it went and how I
should go through it and she said yeah
provisionally I'm happy with that
and she said would you be interested in
taking on another property like that
so I said yeah just run me through you
know me food figures so he went through
those figures for both properties the
first property it comes down to well
her mortgage is about 190 because it's a
flat as a service charge so there's also
an annual service charge of 360 pounds
taking into account all the costs and
one of having a property and obviously
the rental she's actually got tenants in
there in a minute for both properties
although obviously the rental so it
needs to be increased she's had them in
there for a while so she hasn't
increased the rent for any of them but
the property of the property for the
first property should be about two
thousand seven hundred you know that's
keeping the current tenants with the
same rental but if you increase the
rental it should be about three thousand
eight hundred and forty pounds that's
the general calculations I've come to
and the second property which is a
terraced house in Shropshire that's come
up to four thousand four hundred seventy
pounds profit per year Austin for both
of those because of the profit per year
taking his account all of the costs that
can be the property she's actually
agreed to for a purchase price for both
properties which are below market value
now
the current market value of that
property is I think it is a hundred and
four thousand times I just double check
that yeah a hundred five thousand seven
hundred pounds at least the value of the
first property and the value of the
second properties 123 thousand pounds
and as an agreed purchase price of only
twenty seven thousand pounds so it's
quite good figures on something that I
literally did in a few minutes so quite
happy with that and then we said in that
first property along the one that has be
three thousand eight hundred and forty
pounds profit per annum I'm gonna be
selling that to pay for the second
property which yeah
massive massive respect to that kid and
also everybody else has been messaging
me dear me on Instagram commenting on
YouTube is also hustling making money as
a property entrepreneur from home during
this lockdown
well everybody else is born in abundant
excuses this is the time when we need to
stand together we need to be positive
and when it remember that this is
possible listen guys if you enjoyed the
content please do smash the like button
also don't forget to subscribe to the
channel
put together a playlist of all about
lease option agreement so if you're
thinking what did he do exactly
then you should check out this playlist
right here and see how you can buy
properties using little non of your own
money
also if you want to package and sell
deals making money from properties that
you do not even own from home and check
out this playlist up here and there's a
ton of content there also you can
subscribe right here do it subscribe
spread the love spread the positivity
I'll see you next video
peace out lock down property challenge
complete now it's your turn and I'll be
helping you do that